welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and moon knight opened up the
marvel cinematic universe to a depth of
mythology and religion in a way that
we're all still coming to terms with
because if heaven is standing alone in
direct sunlight listening to christian
hymns and hell is playing lava monster
and a sandbox is an overcast sky purple
rains more party animals for me to
torment you go ahead and take tower rat
to the moon for me i'm gonna bing-bong
here in the duat despite producers
claiming moon knight would not really
connect much to the mcu these few words
spoken by hippo goddess do more to
define marvel mythology than most other
marvel titles who claim to do so did and
smartly it does so in a way that does
not limit the mcu to any one particular
metaphysical path but opens doors for
however future projects wish to
interpret things giving us endless
kool-aid flavors to try i am going to
explain the full implications of the mcu
afterlife according to moon knight and
by the way we do have a few remaining
tomb in the moon guide shirts available
at newrockstarsmerch.com it's really the
best way to support us here new rock
stars so moon knight episode 5 reveals
that mark and stephen psykward is
actually their visualization of an
afterlife realm welcome
gentle traveler
travelers
to the realm of the jewish duot the
egyptian underworld this is the
afterlife the afterlife and afterlife
not the
afterlife
you'd be surprised how many
intersectional planes of untethered
consciousness exist yeah ah like the
ancestral plane oh just gorgeous because
the duat's true nature is impossible for
the human mind to comprehend right you
may perceive this realm as something
more easily recognizable to you now it
is incredibly important that towerette
cited the ancestral plane the afterlife
realm of the wakandans introduced in
black panther both that afterlife and
this one operate under similar rules
one's afterlife is based on whatever
your earthly beliefs desires and fears
were for t'challa it's an african
savannah with a tree containing his
ancestors taking the form of panthers
for killmonger it's the oakland
apartment where his father died and now
for margaret stephen it's a psych ward
reflecting the role mental illness has
played in their lives tawara calls these
intersectional planes of untethered
consciousness and suggests that there is
an endless number of them like the soul
stone way station that thanos visited
infinity war could be one intersectional
plane as for him it took the form of a
zeho beret gate where he first met
gamora a manifestation of his guilt for
killing her to acquire the soul stone
the ancient one ventured into the astral
plane at the moment of her death but the
astral plane isn't always an afterlife
as characters like doctor strange wanted
bruce banner and peter parker all went
into it while they were still very much
alive but for the asgardians the
afterlife is depicted as valhalla where
warriors bodies disintegrate and float
up into the heavens but we have not yet
seen what valhalla looks like on the
other side and then the other side of
that coin in loki episode 4 loki thought
the void was hell in the closed
captioning spelled it h-e-l suggesting
the existence of the norse punishment
afterlife of hell the fact that loki saw
this space and figured this hell might
have been custom designed for him goes
along with what tawarit is saying about
the way afterlives work tuaret says that
the duat's true nature is impossible for
the human mind to comprehend meaning
this afterlife does have some specific
ethereal quality beyond human perception
but that it just shapeshifts to suit
whatever our beliefs are this actually
comes directly from how the asgardians
were retconned in more recent marvel
comics as aliens in a specific stage of
a celestial mutation cycle so that they
take the form of whatever their
believers make of them so in norway in
965 a.d they saw odin as a gold-plated
viking king and so he was now it's
fitting for the egyptian duat in the
wakandan ancestral plane to be connected
like this and for that to be touaret's
go-to example as wakandan deity of bost
is derided from the egyptian feline
deity of bostet now in mcu lore the
black panther prologue showed how the
vibranium meteorite crashed into the
african continent in 2.5 million years
bc and then in 10 000 bc the five tribes
of wakanda united behind bashenga who
received a vision from bost and ingested
the heart-shaped herb and became the
first black panther i mean you could
even make an argument that bashing might
have been boss's avatar now eternals
added to this history their arrival in
5000 bc in ancient mesopotamia and from
that point forward 80 mankind with
technology and culture the implication
for that film is that much of human
religion and mythology in the mcu greek
figures like athena and icarus was
derived from these synthetic alien
caretakers named thena and icarus
spelled differently which now poses a
pretty interesting question for thor
love and thunder which will introduce us
to actual gods from olympus like zeus
ares hercules and presumably by
extension the real athena now we know
the eternals were aware of the asgardian
gods based on gilgamesh's line yours is
a secret group
alden taught me as a thank you thank you
after you helped me peel off his army
speaking about thor used to follow me
around when he was a little kid also
they're drinking beer brewed at the
battle of troy so presumably they were
aware of greek mythology as well so why
did aresham and other celestials name
one of their synthetic alien caretakers
after a real goddess who exists
elsewhere in the cosmos my theory for
now is that this was intentional by the
celestials maybe even with the real
olympus's consent to use their names on
earth to help fool those terrans while
they nurtured this planet to tiamat's
hatching point this corrupt alliance
between the celestials in olympus might
even be part of the reason gore the god
butcher's now targeting all of them if
my theory about gore's family dying on
that planet century six is correct but
regardless this diversity of all these
religions across the mcu that i've been
talking about is why tuareg's wording is
so important she does not say that the
duat is the one true afterlife and all
others are variations of it she name
drops the most well-known afterlife from
a marvel film as a way of charting a
course for however the mcu wants to
explore the intersection of real-world
religious iconography with this
fictional universe the implication is
that all religion-based genesis stories
in the mcu can have tangible
explanations based on supernatural
entities and this is going to get really
interesting when we explore christianity
in the mcu something moon knight has
already done in small doses opening the
first episode with bob dylan's christian
spiritual hymn every grain of sand and
ending episode 5 with masaya del sol a
spanish language christian hymn also the
christian god was mentioned back in the
2012 avengers film these guys come from
legend they're basically gods there's
only one god man and i'm pretty sure he
doesn't dress like that but this is also
the same movie that actually spelled out
mephisto's name in inc and that's not
enough for you people thanks for nothing
joss but mephisto or memphis no
christianity is about to play a much
bigger role in the mcu with devout
catholics like matt murdock satanists
like agatha harkness getting her own
spin-off and mutants like apocalypse
reframing our understanding of the old
testament now i don't know if the mcu is
about to say jesus christ was based on
adam warlock or anything but the
christian tenets of god and lucifer
heaven and hell thanks to juarez are now
part of an array of fictional afterlives
in the mcu shaped in these ways by the
true believers who occupy them you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos following rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you